[Music]
um hey who's this Virgie well we're
about to let me let me tell you we gotta
we got we got Mercy's girl
uh we got a little another little update
from Eliza [__] by the way shout out
to fair and balance who got uh who got
me a little I got into a little trailer
she's working on she's doing a whole
she's doing a whole [__] hit piece on
this [__] and I was in the trailer and
I was like hey yo
so
right now would be a great time to start
for supporters only five dollars and up
is when it starts in one minute
um so here it's starting now thanks for
reminding me Frozen [__] one job
um
sorry thanks bud uh okay so remember
that her argument was
um she brought this up yesterday but her
argument was that she did not give
consent
for that video to air that she didn't
want to do that video that she wasn't
the video that you clearly that was so
professionally done that you clearly
would have had to sign a release for
yeah no I believe her yeah where he was
she was non-consensual video okay
here's the thing though because it's the
internet somebody found the clip of her
talking about the video when it came out
remember she said she don't want to be a
part of it here you go
that's good peace to the puzzle
um
what was that let's listen to that again
that was
to the puzzle
oh that sounds like someone that was
happy though that she was in that world
star video and that it was released
she she is infinitely more gross when
she talks black like this
like like the same woman
can just speak normal
and you're like okay that's fine but
there's something about that like and
like I'm not even talking about being a
little Hood like some people do have a
little Hood in them I'm talking about
the full-blown Minstrel like damn y'all
yo this world star thing gonna blow up
y'all like you know you're like what are
you doing why are you you're I feel like
you're doing a character right now this
are you auditioning for SNL did she also
do that this [__] is kind of [__]
wild I mean I I saw the quartering said
that
uh is after the show yesterday but the
quartering the boring Jeremy not to be
confused not Jeremy boring Jeremy
um we gotta make that stick yeah uh he
he said something on his show that
um
Elon won't let him back onto Twitter I
guess all he now correct me if I'm wrong
I think virgin a little bit more about
this he's in the New York Post situation
right now if he takes down the thing
he's he'll be unlocked from the thing
right now I don't think he should have
to obviously let me be cool I don't
think he should have to [__] take
anything down
um but at this point Elon Musk Mr I want
to get involved in everything and he's
every little thing that's going on
because he sure was talking to his Eliza
[__] [__] he's real quiet now right
like what's going on it's been dead
silent and everybody's I mean he has
there's no way he hasn't seen the
trending stuff right he's there's no way
he hasn't been to he's been tagged by
way too many big accounts he knows
what's going on yeah there's no way he
hasn't seen it this silence is
definitely the rest of everybody hasn't
seen her Trend if you noticed even
though [__] thousands and thousands
of people are attacking her and tweeting
about her ain't that weird ain't that
weird that she's never popped up she
should be trending yeah and she was
getting yeah that that this there's some
spoopy [__] Happening Now free Britney
or free the quartering hasn't [__]
trended at all even though you know
they've been [__] people have been
tweeting that [__] Non-Stop
I like how I've been back on Twitter for
two months and I already want to burn
this [__] down again
this woman bro no they haven't even done
anything to me and I'm like it's like
you just it's like going back to your
hometown and being like
these [__] is gay
why'd I come back here God do I feel
that
like you go back for Christmas and
you're like ew I hate this
um
uh you got some nice pennies though yeah
me right now I'm trying to no so do I
kiss
[Laughter]
Ed
um and what I'm doing right now is I'm
working on Mercy have you tried not
being a jerk because maybe if you
weren't oh yeah sure people would have
respected you a little bit more buddy
hey Royce maybe maybe I'm alone in this
maybe you just don't know what it feels
like to be five years of screaming
about the same like I know I know and
then and then when uh when they finally
go man I'm starting to think this might
be like a real [__] person I'm like oh
really really you're getting that
impression and then they're like I don't
know why you're gonna be such an [__]
about it
it was funny because when I woke up the
morning the first time you were fighting
with her and there were all that stuff I
think it was Virgie and Patsy and
apparently goes yeah Mercer's fighting
on Twitter but hear me out
he's a hundred percent right that
honestly that's exactly how it was like
and I read and I go oh yeah she's a
[__] [__] [__] this [__] every once
in a while I'm right no and this is [__]
she is now shout out to at least some
people because um obviously Brittany
bendy should have been [__] punished
and neither should the quarter and
regardless of how cringe you may or may
not think any of these people are they
shouldn't be [__] pop from for
posting something that's 100 true
um but also I gotta give a shout out to
Chrissy Moore and Frank too who both
were like you look we had our new kids
she's not dealing with clubs that's a
good point I forgot about it who cares
about Chrissy I forgot she's where's the
[__] deal
I can't not do it every time you have to
you have to do it
it's my favorite thing ever like social
media
um
I want to have it it's really hard to
explain because it's basically because
it's not true it's really hard to
explain because I'm making it up as we
go along
and why I started
anything like if if it's not gonna be if
it's not gonna trip my trigger gotta
trip my trigger and give me like a fire
in my belly I'm not gonna do it why is
her nose I'm sure you've had plenty of
those
the makeup that she does sad
honey so bad
shoots for BS like I'm not doing all
that type of stuff anymore like I'm
really just focusing on stuff that I
really like seriously she looks like
lying on Twitter and have everyone
believe you
was she also on the daily why didn't
didn't Shapiro interview her
uh I don't I I don't think so she might
have been on the daily wire it would
have been like a Candace Owens or one of
the you know the B Squad I I don't know
for real like she's not gonna she's not
gonna get to sit down with Tupac but she
might get to sit down with the Outlaws
no no thanks
you know biggie ain't gonna be in the
studio but you might get to meet little
cease no thank you I swear to God I was
about to make a little cease joke
you son of a [__] I know you see me you
haven't slept in 24 hours by the way I
know you see me in the videos true
pavlovy in them yeah I know you can't
help it you can't help that
oh [__]
but still don't give me no attention
Okay Royce is from Miami start singing
can a [__] get a table dance okay let
me explain to this [__] minds
somebody once asked me are those Bugle
Boy jeans you're wearing and I said hell
no ho you know they Polo because that's
how I roll Trick Daddy bro all day air
day
um
honestly uh uh I'm a thug was like
that was that jam that like went way
outside of Florida
that was the trick Daddy's was That
Trick Daddy all right baby because I'm a
thug yeah all day every day yeah that
was that was one of the only like the
main Trick Daddy songs early on there it
didn't matter that went way outside of
the people from New York like North
Carolina everybody was bumping that I
just take half a pill it's a set of
hills and I'm like whatever dog yo take
it to the house was the same year too
take it to the house with another bank
or take it to the house
but I'm talking about like you know
people that like to listen to real [__]
that's right [__] oh [__] on the
radio
and then of course sorry Eliza see she's
so boring uh
uh a boring Eliza not to be confused
with Jeremy boring or boring Jeremy
fair enough okay good
um
this is her on the Michael malice show
thank you AG look by the way who sent
this in about this is her this is her
story about another story about being
sex trafficked you ready oh my gosh um
act on Twitter as well
been three profile
okay
yes
my dog my dog walked past my [__] my
headphones and got tangled up like in my
cable so I was like lean down to [__]
fix it
that's why I was like far away from the
mic what she was trafficked on Twitter
Fergie don't you laugh at her oh [__]
that was really that was this is the
clip I was talking about this is the one
wait till you hear this guys all right
here we go
um I was trafficked on Twitter as well
so there's been three profiles to my
knowledge that my former abusers made to
traffic me on Twitter I didn't realize
because I kind of just signed up for
Twitter in uh late 2019 so it was like
the one of the last few days of 29
yeah if you make fake profiles over at
sex trafficking did you know that yeah
wait hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on go back oh it's identity theft
for one but okay
no because I I can fry this [__] on
this one all right let's go ahead um I
was trafficked on Twitter as well so
there's been three profiles to my
knowledge that my former abusers made to
traffic me on Twitter I didn't realize
because I kind of just signed up for
Twitter in uh late 2019 so it was like
the one of the last few days of 2019 I
signed up for Twitter what does that
mean that they trafficked you on Twitter
how can someone traffic you if they're
not in contact with you
thank you for asking that thank you yeah
so the way that that was working I
didn't know about the about the profiles
existing because I wasn't on Twitter and
I wasn't looking for them uh the way
that my former abusers were doing it is
that it was going back to my Instagram
the Twitter accounts were linking back
to my Instagram and they were
trafficking me off Instagram I don't
think what okay hold on hold on hold on
man man man you keep saying the word
trafficking and I don't think you know
what it means yeah I think you're I
think I think you think the trafficking
means so posting the social media cross
posting essentially no no no no no no no
no no did I get sex trafficked every day
yeah because remember we almost built
that website with those guys and they
were going to sex traffic us well they
were going to set everything up to go on
all the things
wow did we get sex trafficked we
potentially could have thankfully you
caught it early
she's literally covered no you know what
this is you know what all this is this
is her trying to [__] front lash and
cover for whatever [__] other Twitter
account she has that are sitting out
there under her [__] name is that
what you think no I that's what I
[__] know because she said there's
three accounts Eliza seep Eliza knows
Eliza cuts
and then she mentioned that one of the
fake twitters was linked to her
Instagram how did it get third-party
access uh exactly
this is her [__] covering in advance
for [__] hey hey uh autist in the
chat and also me uh there's three
accounts sitting out there that we need
to find and also me
and also me Virgie when you watch this
10 minutes from now
Virgie had to send himself reminders I
do because I'm [__] back page
um you know sugar daddy websites I mean
it all right whatever 15 minutes from
now check all sugar daddy websites oh my
God that's what she's doing she's
covering for anything that [__] pops
up because [__] remember the [__] the
cam girl [__] popped up yep
here you go here let me let me give
these autists a head start go to Wayback
machine and start looking for [__]
accounts on Wayback machines through
[__] uh through sugar daddy sites for
Eliza seep and Eliza knows you'll find
them okay
they're [__] there
it looks like a profile um in my
particular case the profiles look like
profiles that would be me but
wait a second look the criminal hear me
out hear me out hear me out hear me out
hear me out the criminal is gonna look
and talk exactly like me but it's not me
okay
it might have been a room in the
spaceship made to look like a room at
the Holiday Inn in Paramus Best Line in
that movie Royce Best Line in that movie
you come downstairs tomorrow and I'm
sitting and eating a stack of pancakes
it is not me but no it is
I really wish this woman was in this
situation where you'd have a Bill Murray
interviewing her yes so you were sex
trafficked through Instagram
to sell me bringing it back to my
Instagram poll and chat said should have
remembered your passwords [__]
get a password manager where they were
doing business or a business manager
um fortunately in my particular case
there are no nude images or videos of me
on Twitter
yet
thank God right now
uh oh wait a second wait a sec that
means they're out there then right yeah
that means they're out there well she
was cam Girling for a couple years so
the day is Young I guess but um but it
would go back to my Instagram and that's
how they would traffic yeah it's Young
tell me without my full consent and
without my knowledge when I joined
Twitter uh an ex-boyfriend actually
pointed out the first uh profile after I
reported it to Twitter was it a black
ex-boyfriend or it took them three and a
half months to take it down the second
profile took five days hey yo [__] you
got another Twitter account the [__] is
this
only use the phone I got you from CVS
actually took it while I was on my way
to do my I got you a thousand minutes
[__] now use the Straight Talk phone
and you're gonna be talking straight for
a week anyway when I slap the [__] out
of you make up a minute count how yo hit
me up on my next tell I was sex
trafficked on a Boost Mobile phone
where you at Dog where you at where you
at
where you were a dog right they took it
down while I was on my uh way to do my
interview with Tim with Tim cast and
when when your boyfriend called you did
it say did it say you have a call from
the Rikers Correctional Institution
before you had the [__] to him
and uh and then the third profile the
platform has refused to take down
okay so I don't understand so there's a
someone creates a fake profile of you
there's photographs of you how are they
monetizing this how is Twitter getting
is Twitter getting a cut like what's
literally happening yes so Twitter
question why is Michael malice's hair
kind of look like a tough now I don't
know it's weird no it was actually more
like why it was actually more going to
be more why is Michael malice yeah like
like just what like isn't he supposed to
be funny like like I've seen him on
other shows that he's pretty funny he's
humorous this is
uh cut off all of our twitters that's
all he deserves I love it yeah he's
numerous yeah he's humorous based off
advertising sales and data sales so any
profile that's on Twitter uh did they
get a cut of it okay because you're
saying we're all trafficked oh my God
we've been trafficked again oh my God
twice in one day my money twice in one
day I don't know I'll tell you oh my God
it's better than the years
why have neither of us done this I'm
changing my Twitter bio to sex
trafficking Survivor right now yeah they
can't stop you
they can't stop you
the exploitation of people through
forced coercion threat and deception and
includes human rights abuses such as
debt bondage deprivation deprivation of
Liberty and lack of control over freedom
and labor
okay so how do you do that on Instagram
uh
that's my question now you don't
you don't
say it to um Pepsi Coca-Cola whomever
they're doing business with uh we have
this many active users on our platform
imagine this [__] this [__] God
damn this [__] this goddamn cam horror
just mud shark coming out and into
Twitter and trying to tell them how to
run their business and then the twist is
it [__] worked
it worked holy [__]
wow
Jesus [__] Christ
so was it dick Masters it might have
been dick master on Twitter it says wait
are you telling me that Elon Musk fell
for this for this for this act and he's
supposed to fight against the
intelligence agencies get out of here
you know what I mean well yeah he said
that well I think I think his tweet was
like man at least the old Twitter had
the entire [__] state department and
the CIA on their ass this guy just
[__] folded for one like 40 year old
woman yeah he's like we're [__]
in essence you and I are definitely
making the money when it's a free
platform we are the product yeah well
the thing is about your product is that
you sold it way too many times so now
it's become [__] worthless
do you hear me
I don't know how many I I don't know how
many I caramba shirts we needed in the
90s but we had too many a lot of them
and you're an eye caramba shirt okay no
no no no no no I'm sorry guys no she's a
shirt you get in Chinatown with a black
Bart that says the caramba
she doesn't even get that that's not
even true because I could wear that like
retro and like it would be cool again
you're as useless as let's say a Buffalo
Bills Super Bowl champ shirt yeah that's
a really good point that's a really good
point
uh
uh you're you're about as useless as as
all those R.I.P Demar Hamlin shirts they
had made
I was actually going to say you're as
useless as Demar Hamlin's body double
that guy sucks yeah
that's so [__] robbing the chat goes
she's literally a 40 year old scene girl
oh God yeah you're right that's what she
is she's a 40 year old scene girl oh
that's so bad manic pixie nightmare girl
that's what she [__] is wrong
anyway
plur I haven't heard that in years
that's a raver joke you want to come
back to my place this is some AFI
um we are the product
but how are these people who are using
your images making money themselves
well they're not Michael let me answer
this for you uh Eliza If you don't mind
I got this one they're not because she's
[__] lying to you
so right it would depend
um so my truck my trafficking situation
is going to be a little bit different
than what we're going to talk about with
the children so yeah because they're
actually getting traffic
yeah because listen if Eliza's thing
isn't true the kids thing isn't true
tell the kid tell the kid
oh I'm sorry child who thinks you're
being [__] molested and raped you're
not getting better
account by the way Fergie Fergie she has
triples of the Twitter account
safest
you know I think we found the one time
when triples isn't safest this is not no
oh [__]
yeah you were raped repeatedly at a
hand-dug basement cell but were you
bullied by at Pepe LOL 26 I don't think
so
oh there it is that just it just came in
the deal went through now she has
triples of the cam horse
[Laughter]
yeah but you know there were three music
videos I know I know particular case can
we there can we please play one of the
music videos of course send me whichever
one you want we're on location we could
do whatever that hell we want I actually
did yesterday so there's one in your DMs
already okay I'm going right now listen
I'm perfectly fine when watching some
sex trafficking videos
[Laughter]
hold on I mean just regular rap videos
yeah
this was my favorite one because it's
the perfect blend of like
oh there it is shitty local black rapper
who funds his music by selling Coke do
it faces
oh God okay this is going to be let's do
this Leroy film
[Laughter]
gonna oh no
oh god oh she's right at the beginning
God no she's very very featured
[Music]
oh no
I know it's already too early but is
this better than the mega rappers yes
yes unironically yes
[Music]
they all [__] her they oh
yeah
she came out of that looking like a
donut
myself
a [__] glazed a glazed ass Donut oh
God
wow she's so cringe
she's so cringe
why wouldn't she's gross lucky why would
why would they sex traffick you anyway
you're giving it out for free honey like
no what are we doing here now you see
they were trying to push her into
traffic
and someone tried to push her into sex
I don't understand how do you get stuck
in traffic when you're running a train
oh no what no see again no like she
ready okay
it was supposed to be pushed in front of
a train but this is the thing with her
mixed messages all the time with Eliza
she is she is
I would have disliked her before all
this because she's terrible right she's
awful
like everything about she should be on
thought crimes honestly I I never like I
I was on her a long time ago but she's
so [__] boring
without the Streisand Effect stuff and
her panicking and burning her own [__]
to the ground like she was if I had
brought her the show a year ago we were
just been bored and been like yeah she's
full of [__] so uh well because there
was a millionaire for this this this
debacle makes her different than the
other there's a million of her you know
yeah because she's the Jack Murphy of
fake trafficking victims her mug shots
in your DMs is she hot
you guys she's got a good mug shot she's
got a good mug shot okay mug shot you
guys gotta stop being mean to Dollar
Tree Nicole Arbor over here okay oh my
God that's what she is yes she is she's
a Dollar Tree Nicole Arbor she's a
Nicole Arbor then it kind of looks like
tank girl I'll straight up say it my mug
shot was cuter yeah yeah I'll stand on
I'll die on that Hill someone sent
Mauritius to mugshodies
yeah let's get our boy on this guy to be
on there yeah